donc merci d'avoir accepté cette mission
tout simple c'est quoi leur bac ya pas d
arnaque sérieux elles servent aux
enchères chauffer thouars sochaux ça ne
se dit pas s'ils s'obstinent à wipro que
[Applaudissements]
j'ai manqué mon arrêt pourquoi tu te
souviens des deux tares et en bolivie
les juments tu saignes mec alors c'est
pas lui je mangeais un tout d'accord
t'as qu'a laissé tab est grand ouvert
doit jeter tout le monde voit ma cravate
y a pas que moi qui suis sur le coup
dans ce travail
je suis venu me venger je te connais
et ce sera votre tour
ce qui nous attendra que tour la mort ou
blanche avec son arme et à sa soeur il
faut qu'on mette un plan au point
ces reports de toute évidence
nouveau en équipe sérieux tu te souviens
pas bien
où nous mourrons de sol
j'adorerais avoir une bouteille d'eau
d'omar khadr ça me revient j'ai filé
tout fric aux contrôleurs tu
tu veux vraiment pas qu'on en parle ya
pas de raison qu
on est tous
[Applaudissements]
tu connais une toilette intelligente
arrête de jouer avec les toilettes
[Musique]